and I think that one of the hardest
things about raising a teenager is you
actually cannot guarantee your teenager
safety like there's nothing you can do
to guarantee that your teenager will not
find themselves in a position that's
truly
dangerous that is so scary I can say
that both as a parent and as a
psychologist who cares for kids but I
also know that fear is a terrible
position from which to
parent the best gift we can give our
kids especially our teenagers is to try
to be a steady presence you know for
them you know a failed test a you know
ruptured friendship feels disastrous
like that's how they experience emotions
and they come home to us and they lay it
in front of us and the best we gift we
can give them is to be very empathic and
very attentive to it but not to react at
that at their level much less above it